Sở hiểu là thản thích và từng hạt lâu ở nhiều vai trò trọng sử dư,
anh nhật tội vừa bị công an pắt vì diên quan đến mặt ý.
Chức khi vẫn vọng lâu lý, sự nghiệp của nặng nghệ sĩ này thế nào?
Anh nhật tên thật là Lê Ruy Linh, bún mùa tội, được biết đến với vai trò cà sĩ,
nha xí, diễn viên và ông bầu.
Năm 2 nghiên khúc chăm lình sấu anh thăm ra sau mai đẹp hẹt,
nhưng không tạo nhiều giấu ấn ở vai trò cà sĩ, sau đó chuyển hướng sẵn sẵn tác
và đứng sau nhiều bạn hích, gắn với các giọc cà nội tiến.
Năm 2 nghiên khúc chăm lình sẵn sắp nhóm zei Rô này với đội hình tám thành viên.
Tuy nhiên, nhóm đến tục bướng trình kái, bị sò sánh và cân mắt đạo nhái các nhóm nhạc kể bóp.
Đến năm 2 nghiên khúc chăm 2 miệnh zei Rô này ngừng hoạt động.
Ngoài ra, tăng nhật tội còn thăm ra hư năm 4 vìm trong đó có mùi bày phải chính.
Trong thời gian hoạt động dạy chi, anh cũng từng về chủ ý bởi nhiều phát môn trình kái.
Những năm gần đây, năm nghệ sĩ sống kiến tiếng hình, chủ yếu duy trì vai trò sánh sức âm nhạc.